welcome back to new rockstars mouth
Happy New Year hit it Eric boss this is
Phillip Molina and welcome back to the
big question Phillip and I are starting
off 2020 with a slice humble pie no one
knows we're gonna reflect on our
theorizing from 2019 and all the stuff
we okay so this episode I have just I
put it very simply it's the one big
question I ask you every year what did I
do to deserve you
oh good or bad yes I know it's what
theories did we get completely wrong
past year so this is our performance
review right yeah we're having a
performance review with you the viewer
and this is what we own up to this we go
out on a limb but then we call ourselves
out on it last year my favorite was to
call out Eric for thinking that cop
would eat the soul stone uh-huh and
given hustle sun-powered
which now after endgame might be true we
don't know what he might have eaten it
okay but let us start with Avengers in
game this is the the first of a the
biggest thing that we theorized about we
made like dozens of videos pointing in
various different directions we got a
lot right but we got a lot wrong the
first one I want to point out that we
got wrong is that the front-door footage
from the first Avengers in game trail II
remember this of Scott Lang being like
hey is anyone home it's at archive and
upper corner and man oh man did our
trailer breakdown theorized that that
was evidence that Scott Lang had to
travel through time this isn't the front
door of the facility at this moment this
is a old archive video and somehow Scott
is showing up in it now while time
travel did end up being a big part of
the plot that had nothing to do with it
it was not the huge discovery of time
travel archive was just a random detail
that had no effect on the plot which
when no sense to be up there actually
has not an archive and what's so weird
about it it's not like they they just
they chose to design that frame with
having the word archive up there right
first maybe it was being archived in the
immediately immediately yeah yeah
everything's being archived okay so that
mat was wrong looks likes okay the next
thing we got wrong was the theory that
we speculated that Loki did not actually
die or that somehow he faked his death
or that he would be resurrected or my
favorite is that he disguised himself as
the whole and the equals Hulk I remember
the
judging from the issues that hope should
not have remembered these things because
Hulk is supposed to black out like
banner doesn't remember anything that's
that Hulk sees so how did he remember
all this stuff to tell dr. strange about
at the beginning of a infinity war it
was just a weird little plot hole but
Loki's dead he wasn't resurrected in a
sense through time-travel but you did
not describe yourself as Hulk okay so
the next thing that we we got a bit
wrong about in game is that the ending
scene that was deleted from the film of
Tony Stark in the soul realm meeting his
daughter Morgan I have speculated that
the reason that we never saw that is
because Tony was really talking to a
cosmic entity to negotiate to get back a
Natasha Romanov life and that she would
be resurrected in the post-credits scene
of Black Widow yes I am submitting to
you the theory that the Black Widow
movie will feature the resurrection of
Natasha Romanov well since Disney Plus
has come out we have seen that scene it
was just deleted because people didn't
have an emotional connection to
Catherine Lankford and that's the horrea
such a bummer yeah but I did like your
theory that that entity was not his
daughter but rather a cosmic entity
which was a separate theory that you had
about cosmic entities yes that's another
thing that we should point out that we
had speculated that characters like
Chronos in the Living Tribunal would
show up in a ventures endgame and that
maybe even Thanos would team up with the
Avengers to take on that bigger threat
was not the case however the writers did
reveal that The Living Tribunal wasn't a
deleted scene of infinity war when
Doctor Strange was battling Thanos on
Titan that he's gonna take him through
this like wizard duel through the
multiverse and that the Living Tribunal
would try Thanos for his crimes
but was not the case in any game that
did not have it's pretty clear that they
are headed there at some point they're
headed that level of cosmic and I like
that we spected on that I know we also
speculated on who noob Master 69 yeah
dead wrong on that one that was we did a
whole video about who knew master 69
could be and in the video I specular
that it could be Flash Thompson given
the fact that he's a troll not at all I
just completely blanked on the fact that
Flash Thompson blipped
he was one of the people who got tested
away in a snap he would not be around
during that five year period to become a
new master to troll Korg and Thor and
there's by the way there are so so many
theories about who new master yeah yeah
it could be it could be Deadpool could
be a start
Mergen start it's probably no one unless
the creators like an answer law and the
big yeah another one that is probably
wrong was one of our first episodes of
total conspiracy that Howard Stark was
using Zola in the 1970s to try to
genetic engineer a super Sun in his wife
Maria's womb that end of the beam are no
stark Tony Stark's brother may be Howard
was one of those hands-on dads who keeps
bringing home all kinds of crazy
prenatal supplements or in this case a
particular comfort food that just so
happens to be a popular German side dish
that is probably laced with vitamins ola
sir probably not be not the craziest
leap aside from all of it but but the in
the comics tony does have a brother he
does it was based on a 2013 arc of the
Iron Man comics that reveals Arno stark
as someone in an iron lung there was a
sequel kind of tear cap eight the
soulstone theory yes you went in on this
year one of the things we speculate on
is the post-credits scene after ant-man
the wasp where you see ant-man in the
quantum realm and they're all these like
orange quantum healing particles that
are floating around him we speculated
that those particles are pieces
fragments of people's souls that now
flood the quantum realm the moment of
the snap because we tried a time when
the snap would have occurred while Scott
was in the quantum realm in that moment
we said oh there's more of those
particles now so we speculated those are
pieces of people's souls or their souls
kind of like in like the galaxy quest
way of travel we write the particles
that form when people teleport no
probably not the case I'll say though
this one when we went with that theory I
was pretty into it especially at that
time we were still trying to figure out
what was gonna happen with how they were
gonna bring people back and so we got
obsessed with this idea of where do you
store half the University of where do we
go where are they in the meantime
turns out that wasn't really addressed
at all they just didn't exist us but I
actually still kind of liked that theory
I don't know that that there is actually
disproven hey that's the thing here in
the Rock sirs we don't necessarily
believe every theory we put forth
sometimes we just find them interesting
and we would like to think that in
headcanon and fanfiction and like
entertain imagination
we're not trying to be a hundred we're
not meteorologists we're not trying to
perfect
we predict every movie like
meteorologist perfectly predict every
right in most of time they're wrong and
then you call them out on it like we are
right a lot of times but we're just
throwing most of the stuff that we
theorized directly contradicts other
stuff we've theorized so when you watch
a theory video don't go in the comments
be like this is wrong that's not gonna
be the case like just use your
imagination to think about what if it
could be right which is kind of fun now
a lot of these theories were based on
you know comic book origins or crazy
things that are have happened and these
cosmic characters and all that but I
like the the really grounded theories
that went along with the Joker fair
right coming out and the one that you we
almost cut out of an episode of rogue
theory because it was so incredibly dark
and you were just like in a way yeah
this is rogue theory we started our
warding points based off of how rogue
your theories get so I just went real
dark when it came to predict how the
Joker will end and my prediction was
that it will end in a mass suicide of
clowns dead clowns throughout the
streets of Gotham like they'll be
inspired by the joke suicide on the talk
show and one by one like the invitation
they'll murder themselves and it'll just
be streets filled with dead clowns eat
some guy what's also unclear is whether
or not Eric means that a bunch of people
will be motivated to put on clown makeup
and kill themselves or anyone who's a
professional clown and it's defined as a
clown it's just like well we can't come
back from this he's ruined clowns as a
career force yes clown clown them
we also speculated in that episode and
lots of other episodes that it will end
with the Arth reflect killing young
Bruce Wayne yeah instead of the parent
we thought we could potentially head to
almost a flash points of situation where
Thomas Wayne actually is the character
we come to know as Batman I was super
into that I've said it a million times
I'm really into Batman like alternate
universe tales and that I think they
might as well make the if they're and
ocher is one basic yeah they might as
well just lean into that both were wrong
but hey we had fun being wrong let's
move on to Spider Man far from home
another huge movie we speculate a lot of
stuff about what might be the case my
favorite theory that we got wrong was
that Quentin Beck is actually Peter from
the future and or another reality
talking to his young
self warning him about the future to
avoid nope
sounds ridiculous but very cool if it
was that spider-man is also mr. yes you
become the it because it's kind of based
on this idea of Kang the Conqueror being
a young iron ore being an old version of
iron lad you know II the the person
you're battling is yourself from the
future looper right great just based on
that I actually have a theory that I
like less in that I'm more happy it was
wrong and there's the idea that Tony
Stark would appear in this movie as a
Jarvis type oh the AI in the glasses
yeah as if Robert Downey jr. was like
look I don't want to come back unless
it's like in this really lame oh hey
where I'm like obedience software now
yeah but that didn't happen
it's it's still plausible that I could
have recorded versions of himself that
will show up in the future
that's different the like the video he
recorded at the end of India but not
like a Zola style like I'm sorry my
computer
we also speculated that the part from
home post credit scene would feature
would revealed a sinister six or Oscorp
whoever the next villain is I was
totally caught off guard by Jay jonah
Jameson showing up in that post-credit
scene and most of us were but what you
weren't wrong about actually was that we
were gonna get a tease toward the
greater kind of other side of the Marvel
Universe I'm in that movie where we did
get hints for Fantastic Four yes we did
we did let's go in the Game of Thrones
we got a lot of stuff wrong I think we
all look at were surprised by where that
ended up it's as if the showrunners
wanted to subvert our expectations and
do nothing else with the plot and maybe
we were most surprised about the fact
that we thought it would be satisfying
and it kind of wasn't but we my dream
scenario for how it would end
and I put this in a lot of videos that
would end with Tyrion cradling Jon and
Danny's orphan baby we both thought that
they would both die and that it would
end with him telling him a bedtime story
a story that would be called a Song of
Ice and Fire and outside of the door is
Sam and he's listening and he's
plagiarizing okay yeah it ended in ways
that we've covered in many other videos
on this channel Oh another thing we
speculated is that we would see a legion
of dragons I remember like after episode
2 were like is Drogo I'm gonna reappear
with like how to train your dragons
fleet of dragons that attack Iran's
fleet no it was just that uh Iran's
fleet somehow surprised Danny because
she forgot about it yeah now those are
you know what take him we're leaving a
little bit the one that was kind of
small one but it really bummed me out
was that our theory that Jamie would
kill Cersei right did not come true
it both addressed the possibility of
people that Jamie could be azor Ahai and
so he would have to kill his missus
Anissa but what actually it was why it
was such a bummer is because when he
rode away from Winterfell and from
Brienne everyone kind of had to like no
right he can't write after all of this
he's just going right back to her and it
was like well if he's going back to kill
her that seals the whole thing right
it'll all have been worth and it's like
nope that's not at all what he was going
to do to others arms and in a
construction accident yes
we also speculated that the Iron Throne
would be destroyed which did happen
we're right out that but rather than
being destroyed by the knight King and
that no one would win the game of
Thrones is destroyed by the dragon and
bran won Game of Thrones yeah which and
you know it goes and said the number of
theories we had about who would end up
on the Iron Throne I think we mentioned
bran once years ago but no there's no
guessing yeah I was kind of hoping that
it would end in this fatalist
perspective and no one really wins then
I get in kind of wins but now he was
pretty easily killed in episode 3 pour
one out for Game of Thrones yeah it was
fun while it lasts
yeah ok let's move on to Captain Marvel
actually a lot of our theories about
Captain Marvel we're right I know you
know I ended up moving into a house that
is on the street where Captain Marvel
shot in space yep yeah straight in space
the theory that I speculated and this
was like a real light week videos where
I was kind of stretching for ideas one
theory
tell them that you do see what this
video the theory is that Nick Fury built
an underwater shield base beside a place
where a space portal had opened up from
the sunken tesseract at the end of the
Captain America the First Avenger and he
left Captain Marvel underwater to guard
it yeah heard that hundred percent
fanfic that you went on there yeah it
really didn't make sense wasn't it all
closed with what happened in Captain
Marvel I don't know why I thought that
might be true just like a gun
but otherwise everything else when kept
tomorrow we're actually yeah yeah we
pretty good about that mandalorian we
have laws there's about and we are still
kind of speculated you may have seen the
final episode by the time this has aired
but here's just some things that early
on we speculated about the Mandalorian
is that it would actually it would
center around an actually a live Jabba
the Hutt or Boba Fett probably not the
case of the show we also thought that
the kid in the in the flashbacks based
off the trailer was a young Poe Dameron
no it was just mando and yeah we'll see
if time will tell how true my baby Yoda
theory was that it's actually Yoda as
the young age and time is a flat circle
and he looped back around and it doesn't
totally make sense but it was one of my
favorite theories that I went into time
did tell it that is not what happened
yes let's move on to stranger things
season 3 came out this past summer and
the big theory that we went into that
season we didn't do a ton of theorizing
on it but I remember being convinced
that a monster whatever the the mind
flayer monsters would attack the
carnival and hundreds of people would
die we built up the importance of this
carnival because everything was leading
toward carnivals everything this whole
year 20 maybe was all about carnivals
there's a shot where Holly in the
trailer looks down and sees the trees
moving side to side and like we're gonna
see hundreds of people die it's gonna be
like Watchmen and they're just to see
like dead clowns everywhere yeah not the
case it was she saw it and it was
attacking the people in the car it was a
limited body count ok relatively small
body count by the way spoilers on these
properties yes we go through the time
yeah you're right yeah we have spoiled
all these things we are not sure we've
speculate some theories about season 4
that maybe hopper could be connected to
the demo Gorgon that there might be some
time-travel going on in the upside down
connected is a little friendly way to
say what the copper could be the
demagogue area time travel is involved
we've also speculated that maybe the
next season could tie into the accident
at Chernobyl which would be dark to go
into but pretty cool too I mean it's
right there yeah it's right there and
then the biggie is obviously rise of
skywalk now yeah by the time we've taped
this we have not seen rise of Skywalker
yet but just to kind of remind you some
of the things that we speculated on and
you can judge us in the comments and
whether or not we were right we
speculated that Maul will return I hate
I did not think that was ever gonna
happen yeah and by return we mean like
Reza
act in some way we know he's dead and
rebels but like will he will he be
reincarnated in some way clones a
freaking double bladed lightsaber there
it still threw it off so much yeah also
a lot of theories about time travel
mm-hmm
it was a theory that Rey is the same
person as me Anakin's mother and that
Palpatine wanted Rey so we could send
her back in time impregnate her with
Anakin and now have a mom Brannigan
who's force-sensitive
I almost love it even though it's so bad
yeah it's one of the crazier theories we
put up there c-3po is going to have a
conversation with the Death Star yeah
his mind was being uploaded into a ship
the Falcon or the Death Star yeah others
a theory that Rey is a clone bunch of
clones specifically of Rey and she's
just hanging on this is gross meat hooks
that one the jury's out yeah but in the
comments were being treated like we're
idiots
another I put out a theory that kylo is
Maul resurrected or reincarnated yeah
and then we also speculated the film
will end back on the large farm on
Tatooine as of this taping we don't know
whether or not that's right but
presumably some of the things we just
said were dead wrong and that there is a
new non Jedi non Sith order that is
going to be the future of the force yes
we'll see but as we've been saying
throughout this video we did a pretty
damn good job getting stuff right this
year just to quickly brag about this
stuff we got right we did speculate that
endgame would center around time-travel
and/or the multiverse and it kind of did
both
there's not one from infinity war we had
that / yeah yeah we definitely
speculated that endgame would end with
cap getting that final dance with Peggy
that he said he'd raincheck on yeah and
they did that was the final shot of the
movie we had that whole video I still
remember the thumbnails second snap yeah
there would be another snap their inner
absolutely was it just didn't a quarter
people down by another Colleen it was to
destroy the stones but there was a
second snap and we'll say a third snap
to bring everyone back
and a fourth snap to erase half of
anuses people so yeah we were right and
then some we were right about professor
Hulk we had a theory that the next movie
would and we weren't the only ones to
say this but we definitely doubled down
on the idea that the Hulk would fuse his
body with banners mind and that's the
version we would see an end game and
that
why we hadn't seen him in any of the
promo material yeah in the beam right
the the guests at the elementals were
actually illusions being controlled by
Mysterio and far from home yeah I mean
kind of made sense that Mysterio was
probably doing that and also especially
if you've read the early early early
spider-man comics Mysterio does
something pretty similar there's yeah we
speculated that fear how fury would lose
his eye and we definitely put forward
the theory that it would be a cat
scratch based off of the style of the
wound that we saw in Captain America the
Winter Soldier looks like three cat
scratches oversee and I'll say there was
a quick theory at that time that we
didn't get fully behind that that's how
they would adjust Wolverine into the
Wolverine Tiny's tiny claws tiny baby
Wolverine and on that note we did
speculate that Fury could be a scroll
back when we were doing a scroll search
series we put up a lot of theories about
Furies and consistent behavior and while
he wasn't a scroll the whole time he's
definitely scroll in spider-man far from
home and maybe some earlier events - yes
made fun of earlier I just was trying to
have theories off of such a ground a
grounded film like Joker but actually we
were spot on and he's gonna be an
unreliable narrator there's good these
are gonna be dream sequences yes some of
the things are gonna be false as are a
lot of the memories of Captain Marvel we
based off of that trailer early in 2019
we believe that Captain Marvel's
memories were false implanted memories
and that the Kree are actually bad guys
yeah we saw that coming doodle-oo
yeah too long yeah as I mentioned in the
game of thrones we got some of that
stuff right a lot of stuff wrong but
also I think we call that stranger
things season three would involve some
kind of Russian conspiracy in Hawkins
which sounded crazy that Hawkins Indiana
would care would be the base of
operations of some Russian infiltration
but that is absolutely what happened in
season 3 but you know what we get a lot
of right we get a lot wrong and that's
part of the fun
yeah man bag and the question is do we
have fun speculating and yes we do yeah
because as I said it's the speculate
it's a journey it's not about accuracy
it's just about like imagining that what
if could be true and thinking about the
directions they could go and then being
satisfied with the direction they end up
going because thank God they didn't go
to that batshit level in the other cases
that we we almost give them things not
to do yes that's our job here but that's
it for this week's episode a big
question we're so excited to answer
you're a more coarse more of your
questions this year in 2020 keep sending
us your
since hashtag big question at me rock
stars and we'll try to answer all the
the biggest ones so that you know this
can be interactive and you can be part
of this show and part of the stuff what
we do here in Iraq yes also comment down
below with what you want to see more of
if you really love us having to pay for
our mistakes send his punishment ideas
yeah also I thanks to everyone who
submitted two questions just in the
other episodes and thanks to Eric for
this whole past year of going out on a
limb and thanks to you Philip for going
out on that limb with me see you next
time bye guys
[Music]